the thing is not a storyline it's a love
story you know I didn't want to be a
story line I wanted to be a love still
see what happens Cynthia Mike is very
exciting to you together you guys have
been wanting to get into this champion
sent you into chill yes popping bottles
is what is that the couple name chill
yes the fantastic let's see in front of
you which is chill there we go we're
just kind of how we are in this one we
don't which is chilly right living life
and enjoy right yeah I love that
ah so it's been like six seven months
since you guys first met on Steve Harvey
I feel like I want to go with you Mike
how did you land on Steve Harvey to be
one of the guys setting up I was doing a
radio show at Fox and my co-host knew
one of the producers over there and
asked me if I would go on to be one of
the bachelors for a dating game and I
was like whoa and they said we weren't
real housewives I said we want and they
said Cynthia Bailey I'm like oh okay and
of course I didn't think I didn't think
anything of it I don't know what's
expecting thank goodness it just worked
out for us and honestly I didn't really
have a high expectation either I mean
Steve was like I'm advising somebody I'm
gonna find something I was like yeah
yeah honey I have been out here in these
streets I've been on dating apps and
everything in it I haven't found anybody
how in the world you can find somebody
and sure enough on behold they really
like Mike which of course I was like let
me just get out of there you don't have
to be with Mike I have to be with it he
endorsed me she was I'm not gonna pick
that one exactly and then I told him she
was trying to choose another guy on the
show she could have been with this guy
in the land great if the one - excellent
thank you because you were like this is
my yield one Mike Hill is the one like I
cannot believe the words that come out
of my mouth he is the one he is the one
I love this man I don't know this became
a point where we were dating and I was
kind of dating up people and you know
Mike was just super consistent and super
yeah just genuine and great I just like
one day I was like I wanted a anybody
else for you what about you
it's like yeah that's cool just felt
natural
because part was like I would date you
but I don't wanna be exclusive so
finally I was like an exclusive anymore
okay he's saying she was trying to avoid
her blessings
at the rate we're going we're gonna be
married soon Betsy soon great person you
think I'm the right person how long
until we put a ring on that finger so
soon yeah I mean I know that if it's in
God's will for me to be married again
for us to be married then this is the
woman that I want to marry I never
thought I'd say that again because I've
been there before I've had a payment
plan I do know that uh if it's somebody
I want to be with for the rest of my
life it's gonna be Cynthia Bailey that's
the guy on the truck James it's like
weird because we're not in a rush but
we're not taking our time either we're
just going with the flow like we I mean
I feel like we could like I don't know
in three weeks from now I would feel
like it may be like hey man what you
doing today no no no you feel like in
America yeah one of the things that
people keep saying to us is oh this is
so great but do you guys think you
moving too fast you think it's going so
fast hello we're like we're 20 yeah I
can't go faster can I go faster is the
question like I really want to you know
run toward my future with him we're
gonna go at the right time but every
night I asked this woman every morning
wait what do I ask you are you still
happy that's it I just want to be happy
as long as she's happy then I know I
love you guys have not let go of your
hands I know I know they didn't have my
my Trivium gather first day she couldn't
let go of my hand oh one of the things I
was a little nervous about was would he
come on the show but lucky for me well
he was like yeah please sign me up so it
wasn't like that he was like look I if
we're gonna be together and this is what
we're doing and we love each other I
will do whatever I have to do to support
you I just knew that if I'm gonna be in
her life and we're in love and that's
part of her but it's not see the thing
is it's not a story lines of love
you know and I didn't want to be a story
line I wanted to be a love story and
it's real everything you see us do on
this show is genuine it's love I really
care for it right we have a good time
cheers to a love story not a story with
damn that's good it sounds like my
tagline that's for you
it's a love story not a story 12 there
you go
poppin bottles will be poppin range
[Laughter]